are you guys having a good time tonight
yeah oh yeah here we go i'm having a
great time meeting so many new people
just fantastic fantastic vidcon's the
place to meet people
and just really network out it's
fantastic oh it's great this is
fantastic
so excited to meet everybody here and uh
you know party with house of blues so
yeah yeah but i think tonight just
brought like
like new faces friends and it's just
amazing to see like all these great
youtubers that you look up to
and you you kind of want a fan girl and
scream like but then you kind of want to
be like i'm not crazy
i'm going to be like hey with one hand
and behind my back
so it's yeah it's a combination of both
you're just like
i'm doing great i just got here i'm
ready to uh ready to con it up
caught it up is what the kids are saying
these days is that it it's clown it up
con it up like it's a con it's a vidcon
and you just con it up you know what i
mean i was like
i won't be kanye and clowning a little
bit i want to get swarmed i've never
been swarmed before i heard it's crazy
we're excited to meet grace and mamrie
we already know hannah i mean just
hanging out with her makes us feel
cool very cool just seeing her recognize
that
but we're from where grace and mamrie
are from so i want to connect
in the comedy scene from new york tv
yeah yeah i'm just
excited to see a bunch of youtubers in
one room
like when does that ever happen i'm
looking forward to meeting my dad i've
never met my real dad
um so i'm trying to find him and meet
him oh at vidcon
dad con 2013 is happening i'm starting
it
i'm i'm for it i'm there you heard it
here first dad con 2013
only for dads dads only i'm gonna like
try and crowd surf
across the bar and then off the balcony
already sweaty
we need the ac on but what can you do
okay will there be any crazy dancing
from the two things yes
we don't know how to twerk but we try
you're really happy
we've already started dancing a little
bit and
we hope to continue it we would hate to
speak on it
it's one of those things it's better
just to do it and not talk about it
yeah go ahead today i had a secret meet
up and at my secret meet up
people know that i love soap so this guy
gave me
soap but it's actually it's a real thing
it's a
poop soap and it forms like
a piece well you know what uh i'm a big
fan of new media rockstars
um you guys are really filling the void
i really love the focus that you guys
are putting
on digital video and what's happening in
the space because
this is real news this is important news
and just look at the energy
the vibrancy uh here tonight with all
these creators
doing what they do for thousands of fans
i mean last year
i was here during industry day it was
pretty low-key
today on industry day there are
thousands of youtube fans
shrieking over their favorite youtube
stars is unbelievable